assalamu alaikum greetings and peace how
are you guys doing welcome to the d
show subscribe if you haven't already
hit that notification bell
so you can get new and upcoming shows
sent to you
now recently i was asked to comment on
something that
the ufc champion mr johns jones de bone
said let's go ahead and listen to it and
then i'll give you my
reaction
[Music]
[Applause]
he said it and that's a powerful
statement
very profound and powerful i did a
program not too long ago where i
explained
some of the common terms that another
one of his friends says
habib excuse me guys alhamdulillah
i wanna say something he says
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah says these things and
maybe he did it because he heard khabib
saying it
and maybe he watched our video where we
explained the breakdown
of it what it means the significance
behind it
and when you know that it's very
powerful but i look at it as an
invitation
from john jones for us to have a nice
little conversation and inshallah god
willing
he gets this message and all the fans of
john jones also get this message too now
the one thing we'll start out with a few
we'll we'll break it down like this i'm
going to start off with one thing and
have him think have you think
imagine walking into a house because
this all reflects around this statement
that he made
alhamdulillah and at the end
he went on to say all praise and
gratitude and glory
is to the creator of the heavens and the
earth without god i am absolutely
nothing all glory be to god
now imagine walking into a house in the
first room of the house
there's a man telling you to worship
another man
it could be a woman it could be anything
in creation
what would you do what would you do
imagine that i think we do pass any sane
human being
would say you know what i'm not going to
worship worship another human being
rather be a messenger a saint anybody
room number two you walk in
and you see stick stones and bones idols
all over the place
and you're invited to worship these
idols stick stones and bows
mr jones what would you do
i think you did the right thing if you
declined let's move on room number three
you walk in
and now the roof is off the top of this
portion of the house and you look up and
you can see the sun and the stars and
the mountains
and the nature some call it mother
nature now you're invited to worship one
of these things
what would you do i think you're very
intelligent and sincere if you declined
to not just the first one the second one
and the third one
moving along you're going to the fourth
room in the house you walk in
there's no stick stones and bones no
one's asking you to worship a human
being
a saint a messenger a woman money none
of these things
but someone is going over
the attributes of the creator telling
you
that this creator he's unseen you don't
see him so there's nothing to look at
but you get to know him by his beautiful
attributes
that he's the most loving the most kind
the most just
that he's one and alone worthy of
worship
that he's not a man or a woman but he
created man and woman
that he's unique absolute eternal
he's not the father of anyone nor was he
fathered
now some people might stop because
they've been programmed to believe that
god has a literal son literal i'm
talking about
now think about that you know cats have
kittens
dogs have puppies cows have calves if
god had a literal son
what would that imply that god had
another baby god then you'd have two
gods
doesn't make sense so when we continue
on and we say this person is
describing actually god is talking
to the human being about himself these
attributes and qualities otherwise it'd
be left to us to make it up
on our own but it's something that fits
that he's one and alone worthy of
worship unique absolute eternal he
doesn't
become born and die he doesn't get tired
sick
eat get hungry go to the bathroom no
these are not qualities of god and he's
not the father of no one nor did he
father anyone
and there's nothing comparable to the
one
creator now you choose
one two three or room number four
this is just an example an analogy
that you can go ahead and think
logically because when you said
alhamdulillah
oh man i'm gonna gotta
you chose room number four you said that
you just need some nurturing now
because when you said alhamdulillah you
said that
there's nothing worthy of all
praise and glory except the creator of
the heavens and the earth
alhamdulillah point number two i want to
bring it home
is that jesus peace be upon him this
mighty messenger
he also said alhamdulillah jesus
yeah that's right his name was isa
now what did he say in mark
10 18 or what we have left of the bible
because we know we don't have a copy of
a copy of a copy
of anything original bible scholars tell
us this people of course call the gospel
books matthew mark luke and john
well they call them matthew mark luke
and john because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them sam fred jerry and harry i mean
they're
they're written by people we don't know
who they were written by they are
anonymous you might not think so because
they have the title the gospel according
to matthew whoever put that title on it
was an editor
later the followers of jesus were
aramaic
speaking peasants from galilee lower
class
men who were not educated
in fact peter and john in acts chapter 4
verse 13 are literally said to be
illiterate
they couldn't read and write of course
not they were fishermen they didn't go
to school
the vast majority of people in the
ancient world never learned to read
let alone write and their native
language was aramaic
these books are written in greek by
highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in greek
composition
so what we have there attributed to
jesus
he said when one came up to him and said
oh good master
what good thing can i do that i may have
eternal life jenna paradise
meaning how do i get to the real home
because this
home is short-lived you know that mr
jones mr john jones bones
this life is going to end it's short and
all the messengers of the creator sent
to guide humanity who came with that
same message worship the creator not the
creation
they also warn people about the hell
fire the carrot and the stick
human me who human beings need
motivation so they warn people of the
hell fire
if they follow their whims and desires
and worship another god next to god
and they also gladly gave the glad
tidings so this
individual came to this mighty messenger
jesus said good master
he's praising him saying good master and
add some more praise to that if you like
he's praising him saying what can i do
to get to paradise
look at the response attributed to jesus
he said
why are you calling me good there is
none good
except the creator of the heavens and
earth look he's saying alhamdulillah
he's moving out of the right way and
directing
all of that glory all of that praise
to the creator of the heavens and earth
alhamdulillah
so mr john jones we cover these two
important points
and i'm going to leave you off with the
third the third goes something like this
that every human being should want to
know how they ended up on this earth the
same way you'd want to know how you
ended up in the cage
how you ended up in this world is even
more important
more important than how you ended up on
a train or airplane
and then why are you here what's the
purpose of my life
what's the goal it doesn't make sense mr
jones
mr john jones my friend and everybody
else his fans watching in tuning in
that you'd be put here on this earth and
there wasn't an ultimate goal
imagine being in the ufc cage
and there was no ultimate end there was
no goal you know what the goal is to get
the submission
to get the tko to finish with a win
imagine life being without a goal of
purpose
that doesn't make sense but many of us
are living life without
an ultimate purpose and i'm not talking
about the means many people take the
means
as the ultimate goal and then where are
we going
when we leave this earth remember mr
jones
john jones my friend that every day
that's why the urgency should be in all
of us to want to figure this out
because every day just in this country
alone
7 000 people approximately die every day
every 12 seconds someone is departing
leaving this life they might have
amassed all the money
all the titles they have
had all the good times included with all
the rocky times the bad times at the end
what do you have
you depart you leave you didn't figure
it out
and i'm telling you once you leave this
life the same way
you cannot just go and say i'm a good
person but you go to work
and you break all the rules or you don't
even show up to work
only when you want it doesn't work i'm a
good person
i'm not harming nobody hey but you're
not fulfilling your duty and
responsibilities at work
what about in the cage you don't show up
for your fights nor do you follow the
rules
of the cage mr jon jones imagine someone
pulls out a
shank pulls out a switchblade
starts to bite eye gouge says hey man
i'm a good person i was just trying to
win the ba the bout no even in the cage
there's rules
even in the cage there are rules and in
this life it's not good enough to say
hey i believe in god
i'm a good person it doesn't work like
that
the creator sent messengers with these
rules
we have them just because certain people
aren't living by them
or majority of people aren't doesn't
mean they're not there
it's up to you to be sincere within
yours within yourself
and to do this little piece of of homer
i don't want to inundate you with
too much information but this is
something for everybody to reflect over
on these questions and this way of life
that we live
we call it the dean the way of life that
jesus
moses abraham isaac ishmael jacob all
the messengers of the creator sent
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
just the last and final messenger
who was sent as a mercy to the world
they all brought the same message
to submit your will to the creator of
the heavens and earth and to put
alhamdulillah
in the center of your life that all
praise and glory belongs to the creator
of the heavens and earth and you strive
to please your creator
before you meet your creator and it's
not by following your whims and desires
now i'll cut out with this and hopefully
they'll motivate you to do the homework
where the creator is saying in a book
that we know
is from the creator the verbatim word of
god the quran you should view it as a
potential book
from the creator everybody should
investigate should put it to the test
and not through the haters not through
the islamophobes
you sincerely on your own you dig deep
down in yourself
do the homework connect with some people
of knowledge in this area
but most of all first and foremost be
genuine and sincere with you
in yourself and ask the creator the one
that you said alhamdulillah
alone for guidance say look if this way
of life the gentleman is talking about
my friend eddie from the dean's show or
these other muslims
like habib and these others that i know
who say
stay connected to god stay connected to
prayer keep it humble
the good things that they revolve their
life around
islam if this islam is the way of life
from the creator
from you guide me to it we just ask the
creator
to guide you this is the homework i want
to leave with you
and then the the verse from the quran is
so powerful and it makes
makes the task very easy almighty god is
saying
now imagine this if you were living
during the time
of jesus he would have been speaking
[Music]
aramaic
[Music]
he didn't speak english imagine if you
can go ahead and quote something from
him in aramaic which is a dead language
but there's a sister language the arabic
and the quran has been preserved
like no other book memorized by millions
all over the world
tells you the purpose of life why you've
been created prophecies
signs upon signs the development of the
human being and
all of these things compiled in his
books to prove that there's no way
that it can come have came from other
than the crate of the heavens and earth
it says in here making your job easy
whoever chooses a way of life
a deen a way of life other than total
submission and surrender
to the creator of the heavens and earth
this is equal with one word
islam because that's what islam means
submission to the will of the creator
whoever chooses other than this as a way
of life a total way of life
that person in the hereafter will be
among the losers
and there's only two places to go after
this life jahannam
the hellfire or the paradise and jesus
and all the messengers moses abraham
muhammad all of them
they call people to the love and mercy
of god
to the paradise and away from the
hellfire so mr john jones
make that alhamdulillah something not
just a trend the train that you jump on
but something that you really live
something that you really want to
connect you with the crater from
and these are those signs because it's
easy
believe me my friend you'd have people
lined up all over you've exceeded
certain heights that many people never
but you got people fighting in backyards
and garages all over the place
but you know where courage comes that
when you find the truth when the truth
comes to you
that you're willing to go up against all
odds to be upon that truth
to be upon that truth it's easy to be
upon a way of life
on a religion that nobody's going to
mock you because
there's no fear of the consequences but
believe me
the truth is going to be mocked is going
to be ridiculed and you see it happening
today with
with muslims in islam so if you're
really courageous
and you really want to please your
creator do that homework and then
as that truth comes to you submit to it
be proud to be a part of it
and live it no matter what everybody and
their mother says
no matter what everybody and the world
says thank you very much
guys that was my reaction to the jon
jones
i hear also that you're part of the
gracie baja academy
and this is from your brother also who
is the first
american rep for here in america of
gracie baja
let's connect let's hook up
alhamdulillah thank you for tuning in
and subscribe if you haven't already to
the dean show where we can
inform you every time a new and exciting
video comes out
hit the notification bell until next
time god willing inshallah
alhamdulillah
you